こんにちははじめ社長です23
滋賀県きました
およげなんで今日ですね私が間にいるかと
いいますと1か月前くらいに酸クエンのお
家にあるトレーニング自分が高いですから
晴れを使わないということでオークション
で売らせて頂いたところ皆さんたくさんの
入札ありがとうございました途中口だけで
何か900バンドが入った時もあったん
ですけどまいたずら抜きで順当に落車2が
されていった結果さ最終的ですねなんと
90万1000円で落札されました
ありがとうございます間近とアグ程度の
自分チング仮復旧とさ90万はないよね
サンダーのなんか砕けた人抜きで順当に
入った結果まずで最終的に90万手順で
落札されたということで誰がダメかそんな
ことをしたのかと気になるでしょ運はどう
いう人がどういう目的でなぜあの自分が
草津されたの気になったということで本人
が出て倉庫に来ております遠く思ってるん
ですよでも誰かたぶんなんかね普通の人で
は無いはずなや間違いですますが一応僕も
どういう形か情報は得ておりまして連絡を
させていただいてるんですけども実践ある
のが今回初ということでちょっといろいろ
お聞きしたいっ
風がを読んじゃっていいですかお願いし
ます
をよちょっといいかおねがいします
いよいよ講座てみましょう
遠山時からどうぞ
はいこんにちは私が落札した岡本です
はじめ長さんはじめましてはじめましてい
ますがネジまあとりあえずん
ありがとうございますこれはかありました
ありがとうございますいや経っちゃいまし
たわざわざしが件まで来ていただいて早速
に関係の日ますボタンと直前に効くんです
か何者なんですか
牧師や件で7店舗飲食
あっインソクサークルくださいそれと今
農家もとだんべんきょたん名をやってるん
ですけどそれを今全国にフランチャイとし
ていますああああああそうなんてない
[笑い]
ブービーチョッチョッちゃんヌードル
きゅん2ならたかけないとかいやでも
もっと行くだろうと思っても100枚って
もが買うといっしょ果実カーで最後にこう
ボタンが誰かが落ちたも負けじゃないです
かその際ごとにブラックさせしました降り
た時に
もういいよこれを決めて自分の筋肉マネー
いやもうぜひ宜しくしますてなんか素敵な
方に落札して頂いて本当自分も喜んでも
いいやままにあれ食べもうすぐで入った二
が届くと思うのであるっ多分いただいて
から人と積極だろうねほど者の短命
パーラー目指していただきました全国に
これから増える静岡にもできますねーまじ
しかあり前じゃないですかうわすごい曽根
嬉しいで床につけるとカモメちょっとまま
じゃないんですけどでもこの動画を見て
くれた人はとが静岡これやりたいか的花火
じゃない確かに誰創著聞けているんですか
ねこそしないが悪化でまずできますよ
そして僕に向けられた
世界 r まおおおい
tus パパぺるぺぽれもう pou
dou
douええええ
ニューヨークのも近来うち使えなかった
これはもう
大阪はれた目のかあってやっほっほいくら
くらい今
相場で行くと多分
完全なんうわああああ
お願いします
[音楽]
じゃーん
効果を
うわーーー
同時このを踏まえ
ここだ前のかっこいいじゃめちゃかっこ
いいでしょ
[拍手]
ああああああめちゃめちゃクリエ表えっ
着衣これをアニメだと家を持ってるんです
か4思っん
1マッハ
すごいやってろあー
始めた東日本
をサインしていただきます
これ
しまって思いますそれもですはい程度53
杯無事にトレーニングジムが届きました
この中で自分があるんですがんばりまーす
をいただきました2
ある
ほとんど岡本さんだけじゃなくて僕もあの
時分あったスペースがこれで綺麗になった
んで行ったちょっとまた使い道が付いる
あるフランといったパリましたブービー3
ですウィンディショ本当に
神軽い
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
ame
tan
ヨシ子
ています
金魚車
アーサ分
can
ohaございました
後に降りましたありがとうございます
はい
単年食いたいです食べていただけるんです
がはいありがとうございますだからうん
よねいやーちょっと切ないですね
願ってさあ頃になってからさ記事月のこれ
が3つ入っていた殺菌部でカップに入った
時からよ
確かにねぇ
カフェの前んそうよ
ん
[音楽]
10万の色
やっていただけるもの
これで世界愛知美しいクルマジャガーに
乗ってらー皆さんいきたいとおもいます
whもうなの動画これに愚痴るどこ行き
ません
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
[音楽]
ええええええ
やりましょう
うわああみ爪
ええええええ
いいねホラーねぇどれめっちゃいるよ
安いの日ビールでも狙う
ほんとさんのズバリを進めば上ばこれ
ぐらいの幼鳥のシーズン a はいた某靴
っていうかいいですいい
ちゃん主玉牡丹面倒チャーハンと卵かけ
ご飯だとオススメはジャーキー
ざあなしていただきます注文したというか
8つ3週にた後3年のキャッチャーな
ペットんだぜ種辛さの方に入ってるから
そうまだこれじゃない
04年忘れられんじゃなくはい
そういう
レーザと動いてる動いてるそうそうだ
源氏洞茶苑ずにじゃあ
すごいなぁ
てきてきてきた場合わー
まあ住田もためのパパになります
ko
を開きますそう
me
ええええええ
deji
言われていた
me
th
ああああああ
[音楽]
dj
あっ
[音楽]
は
blr